uh Samantha who works for us has a
question for you if you don't mind
answering it go ahead Sam well we were
in
like
you're so sexy
sex great sex like
I gotta know how big is your penis why
are you so worried why are you so
curious I think anybody You're such
Ronnie you're such an icon and a legend
Ronnie has that look on his face like a
lion who just spotted a gazelle
[Music]
she wants to know how big my [__] is
yeah she really isn't coming on to you I
don't think I think she just generally I
love you Ronnie but no I'm not coming on
to you I'm I I'm an investigator
average average what is average six
inches yeah a little over a little over
six inches nice hard all right what do
you think of that Sam I I believe that
I'm I'm happy for Ronnie is it
disappointing did you were you
predicting nine inches no I just we've
talked about Ronnie's childhood his
[__] his you know everything and
we've never talked about no I was so
popular how big his penis is I feel like
there was a huge thing that we've never
uncovered by the way my [__] is three
inches open dilated
puppet you have more Dimensions you want
to yeah it's like looking through a
periscope when you look at my ass
well Sam now you know we have a little
bit over six inches and uh I do admit
all the questions I've asked Ronnie the
one thing we didn't know is how big his
penis was how what about girth Ronnie I
I don't know I've never measured that
to make a circle with your finger in
your thumb how how uh Robin I don't want
to see that no what's my finger and
what's my tongue wow that's nice very
nice Point your finger and your thumb
touch no no they don't touch they don't
touch [__] he's [__] how big are
your hands no it's just
no Sam you know what unfortunately it
was an innocent question how big is
Ronnie's penis but here's what's going
I'm just going to take you inside the
head of Ronnie right now okay
I can't believe Sam asked me about my
[__]
she's really hot and she wants it that's
what's going on right now you Unleashed
a thought process in Ronnie you know
what I say only the hungry notice
admit I'm right Ronnie right she has a
curious mind
spank bank material for the night thank
you there you go that's good that's good
there you go Sam now you're all set for
your big night his pointer finger and
his thumb don't touch
foreign